the train station in this polish border
town is where you'll find most of the
refugees here
they arrive daily and with them such
mixed emotions
the relief that safety brings but
uncertainty too and a longing for the
homes they've left
sonia ponomakarenko is just a teenager
but has a role now beyond her years the
ticket is for a journey with her younger
cousins westwood
[Music]
her story gives a hint of such relatable
judgments that families are being forced
to make she explains the family decision
had been that her elderly mother would
remain behind in kharkiv with all the
family pets
sitting nearby we meet anton and his
wife they're from sumi on ukraine's
northern border with russia
and you've seen
[Music]
their story is bittersweet after days
hiding in a basement they are safe now
and they have a motivation to keep going
five grandchildren in germany
but at their age they know they may
never return home
over on platform five something we'd not
expected a long line of ukrainians going
the other way back to ukraine back home
the bittechenko family arrived two weeks
ago now the draw to be home outweighs
the considerable risk that they know
they will face
i just want to go home lisa tells me
when you're at home everything is better
nearby we meet valentina you brought
your mum and your and your baby here
to safety
and now you will go back yes
yes
arena and her husband vladimir went on
holiday to asia before the invasion now
they're back with no hesitation
how are you feeling about going back
good yeah i'm glad
glad to be with your family again
and and you will stay there and your
family will stay yes we will see because
lots of people are leaving now but you
want to stay yes we will stay tell me
why
because it's my country
so many stories so many different
emotions and one war which drives many
away and yet pulls some back
mark stone sky news on the polis
ukrainian border